welcome to this video and put who is
that I'll call Leah cornea that's one of
my clients here eight out of ten so
maybe some chance for him to catch up
considering my recent term rotten phone
but let's see what happens in this game
may always like I mean it's not that I
love this kind of position with white
but I have an excellent score so let's
see what happens at least I know what
I'm doing here in most cases he's
allowing knight c6 really okay king is
only seven so how do you do that he's
probably going to play whoop Dee a
tanned then go back hmm if I could
Bishop e3 he's got 95 maybe that isn't
so terrible I mean it cannot be good but
maybe it's not as terrible as it looks
hmm ok trying to pile up them
yeah i was thinking before him before
so we cannot play king of ATM rook c8 of
courses hmm
Bishop e3 yets a very crude way to play
super crude for b5 yeah maybe I have to
do that but it looks kind of wrong
hmm
um really um c 5 DTX btx roop t4c takes
b6 check 26 push-up t6r up t 6 mm that's
losing a piece be 594 hmm see if I takes
do I have something else there hmm those
position where you would like to have a
little bit more time see if I've d takes
Queen f4 or something like that ok I
have to play a move at some point
hmm the answers I think that's
interesting check stare a big point 9
let's do this like f 3 this is any
better don't know it takes on b4 that's
95 winning the Queen it takes place c4s
be five winning the Queen so I'm getting
somewhere in terms of opening up the
position but it's nothing great still
really should have gone there in the
first place anyway
okay so yeah just this might be
recapturing this let's do it maybe also
a little bit influenced by the time
situation almost two extra minutes
yeah yeah just very slightly better but
nothing serious 90 is ready equal some
ideas like night be seven but that's
very easy to easy to see and that e-cigs
of course but
time warning
check
hmm now G for this always okay i
blundered that pawn kids of course to
the draw but I've got 40 seconds that's
a problem draw Alfred oh that's nice
gain drawn that's really really i mean i
would have played on here with the extra
point it is a draw I mean white will
draw probably but you get some get to
get always get some chance with the pond
but yeah maybe you felt it was unlucky
or anything je blunder that 96 but it
doesn't seem to be that terrible at
least the way I plated it wasn't
convincing if he gets in look to the aid
and King evaded it's really not that bad
what is the engine giving f.3d 8 Queen
deform so if he goes there than 94 hmm
right now I'd retain some some pressure
but it's not like I'm something super
right yeah just Angela can f3 yeah
probably that that before idea is just
not really good it was a bit now I was a
bit too too crude check
yeah maybe I should go to u 3m a
computer gives black a slight advantage
with b5 yeah that's interesting this
kind of thing that looks pretty good for
blog actually not just like slide edge
yeah he seemed to be satisfied with just
returning this and getting to an equal
disposition and you know yet it's really
about equal and 93 was it was probably
better but okay check I will really try
to to speed up to not get into into a
huge time issue I just blundered that
porn very poor probably something like
that and it I think it's still very
likely ending in some kind of draw yeah
the Zen came this NK before he and three
is very likely going to end in a draw as
well but like where the porn always has
practical chances so we should should
try just conceding the draw was was
nicer nice for me but not really am
unnecessary even in terms of etiquette
or something I mean with the pony can
justifiably try to win okay thanks for
watching